so this is an important like I can't
emphasize on port this is for Tesla to
go beyond their ninety-five thousand
dollar Model S yeah although they're
going beyond it in the wrong direction
they're making something that's almost
certainly going to be net more expensive
than the Model S and it's also basically
a model s p85 d that has been turned
into a cross so be 85 days ago to the
top of the line model s sports car this
is this is going to be a bigger yeah
much heavier well it's not gonna be that
much bigger so it's the same platform as
the two engine model ass it's just
they've made it into sort of a wagon so
it's gonna be much heavier it's gonna
have those big heavy doors but this is
basically another model s so we
shouldn't give Tesla too much we should
give credit for great engineering for
building a part of the people will
almost certainly want but let's not give
him too much credit for inventing an
entirely new car I read an analyst note
that suggested this signature serious
car is going to cost 135,000 dollars
plus twelve hundred dollars delivery fee
yeah that's about right i mean these are
expensive car i would let's back up it's
a hundred and thirty five thousand
dollar SUV station wagon yes 135,000
auto station wagon but let's also
remember that Porsche sells 135,000
dollar station wagon that's also a
little bit slower in the Porsche Cayenne
Turbo S Porsche Cayenne Turbo S is can
run you up to 150 thousand dollars with
options so they're actually in a space
where there are price competitive the
Tesla Model S is maybe a little pricier
than if you're looking at a 5 Series BMW
but kind of close to the range if you're
looking at something like an audi a7 now
lest we get too far with the notion of
these cars are now available they're
only making a few of these to hit their
deadline of shipping it before october
right these are the founders series cars
that if you are a Tesla founder and
something breaks you're not going to get
mad and immediately go to Twitter that's
what these cars are they originally said
they were gonna try to build seven
thousand this year which I'm a little
bit skeptical of I'm probably making 20
or 30 of these where we use founders
numbers these founders numbers are
probably even fewer than that i think
that the proto ways we start I want you
to say it again how many cars you think
they're making I think that probably
about 24 maybe twenty four cars let's
give him credit for cars for friends and
family yeah are these production parts
could these vehicles conceivably I read
one analyst notice that these could be
made by hand that what we're seeing
today isn't the actual car and indeed
might not even be production parts and
that much of the car that all of the car
will be recalled and replaced later on
that's entirely possible
but we see this with regular
manufacturers to so the press cars that
go out for us to review are often
pre-production models which are
hand-built which are put together which
bear 99% resemblance to what you're
actually going to get but may have a few
things that have to get pushed together
in terms of switchgear and other parts
so while Tesla has delayed this and
delay this the car was originally
supposed to come out in 2013 that's what
Elon Musk told gerry brownlee 13 2013
was in his car supposed to me well I
said 2014 before I'm wrong no no no 2012
eli must hold jerry brown the car was
coming out in 2013 I governor yeah but
when you lie to a politician it's okay
you can get away with this it's my
governor we're talking about um so bring
the politician he'll be the first to
admit it so is there a history of the
model s where we saw a similar kind of
thing where product was announced if
initial versions a lot of it got
recalled of course there are some issues
with Tesla's in the early days not
recall you know Tesla doesn't do recalls
they're just gonna make some
modifications right they're gonna send
out a technical service they're gonna
make a car better some over there were
updates cuz it all follows the Silicon
Valley model they're gonna ship out
updates just like when you get your you
know you download iOS the new version
from Apple call the recall yes i'll call
the recall it's called an update and
they make you do it the NTSB had some
issues of that as i recall yeah let me
ask finally when do you expect this car
to actually be in production as opposed
to some handmade vehicles crossing going
out the factory doors they're pretty
close and people will start noticing i
don't think Tesla's dumb enough to put
something like this on the big event
saying hey the cars are going out
without starting to fulfill some of the
orders in the first and second quarter
what we want to see though is then be
able to build the 20,000 cars that they
say that they have pre-orders for and
get those done in the next year the
forums online suggest is more than us
there's more like 35,000 people there
were 20,000 earlier this year we don't
have a final number for ludie but also
really importantly there's a there's a
refundable deposit that went out before
the before they know how much the car
was gonna cost just 15 seconds what
percentage of orders do you think it
cancelled because the car is so
expensive weather and the people made
deposits to want together people put up
to put on the positive wait that long I
think very few of them will be cancelled
because of the price I think some of
them may cancel because nobody wants to
right around for two years for their car
so we have to see how quickly Tesla can
ramp up production that's always the
problem with Tesla knocking out of time
you gotta without giving an actual guess